wow that's a lot of options however by
making a list of what we needed in a
tool one of them stands out for our
current purposes envision is the right
tool for us right now I want to delve a
bit into the strengths of the tool to
make clear why we're choosing to use it
first I want to take a look at
interactivity we've already mentioned
this is key for medium fidelity
prototypes and it turns out that in
vision has a concept of hot spots which
maps directly onto our concept of
interaction points to make our prototype
interactive all we need to do is take
our lists of interaction points and make
a hotspot for each of them that brings
us to speed envision allows you to
simply import your mocs or wire frames
into the tool which combines with that
hotspot idea to make building these
prototypes a very fast process and then
its main strength remote feedback is key
to this tool will talk more later about
what this looks like but for now all you
need to know is that in vision allows us
to do user research like we did with
Karl but with someone half a world away
we can do that either in real-time with
live share or asynchronously with a
shared link that's pretty great